our and Ben had a total of five
sandwiches how do we write this using
variables we can write it as a plus B
equals five where a and B are the number
of sandwiches each of them had with just
this information will we be able to tell
the number of sandwiches each of them
had individually well we cannot it can
be 1 plus 4 or 2 plus 3 or 0 plus 5
maybe the point is that there are
multiple possibilities if we have just
this equation now let's say I tell you
that Ben had three more sandwiches than
a Murr in the variable form this can be
written as Ben had three more than Omer
now can we tell the exact number of
sandwiches each of them had yes based on
both these equations we can say that
Armour had one sandwich and Ben had four
three more than Armour and the total is
five sandwiches these are linear
equations in two variables there are two
variables in each equation and both of
them have a degree one so to get the
value of two variables you need two
equations but how to be solved for the
values of a and B let's move on to a new
page to understand that these are the
two equations we have and we need to
find the value of a and B one way in
which we can do that is write one
variable in terms of the other and then
substitute it in the other equation here
fortunately we have B in terms of a so
we can substitute this value in place of
B in the first equation we get a plus a
plus three equals five solving this we
get the value of a as one once we get
the value of one variable we can easily
substitute it in the other equation and
get the value of the other
substituting the value of a here we get
the value of B as 1 plus 3 which is 4
this was one of the ways you get one
variable in terms of another and
substitute it there's another
interesting way the first equation we
have is a plus B equals 5 and in the
second equation if we transpose a to the
left we can write it as minus a plus B
equals 3 now all we need to do is add
these two equations a plus minus a gives
us 0 B plus B gives us 2 B + 5 plus 3
equals 8 we get the value of B as 4 once
we get the value of B as 4 we can
substitute it in any of the equations to
get a substituting it in the first
equation we get a plus 4 equals 5 and we
get the value of a as 1 we got the same
answer but we just arrived at it
differently
the first method will work every time
but may get a bit tedious the second
method is relatively quicker but we were
lucky here as the variable a had
opposite sides in each and it was
cancelled out if you think we are going
fast please go through our background
tutorials where we have explained
everything in depth is there another way
in which we can solve two equations look
at these two equations pause the video
and try solving for the value of a and B
okay if you would have used the first
method you would have been neck-deep in
fractions and that is a bad idea we
cannot use the second method as any of
the variables are not cancelling out so
the only hope we have is modifying the
equations which is in the third method
let's number the equations first
this be the first equation and this be
the second one now let's think a bit if
we multiply the first equation by two we
will get a plus 6b here then we can
simply add them and eliminate the B so
multiplying equation 1 by 2 gives us 4 a
plus 6b equal to 16 which can be a third
equation we simply multiplied each term
by 2 to get rid of B we can write the
second equation under the third one and
add them for a plus 3 a is 7 a B cancels
out and 16 plus 7 is 23 this gives us
the value of a as 23 by 7 to get the
value of B we can substitute this value
in any of the equations if we substitute
it in the first equation it results in
this solving this gives us the value of
B as 10 by 21 so in the third method we
just modified an equation and cut the
values of the variables in just two
steps and yes sometimes we may even need
to modify both equations
you